[Applause]
[Music]
I don't understand can someone just
explain the concept to me
yes suppose we look at hey you're that
guy from T alright yeah I can do that
don't oversell it Maurice hi I'm Danny
Pudi and I'm here to tell you about the
Far Cry 4 map editor Far Cry 4 is an
awesome experience and if you're a fan
of the game you're gonna love the map
editor it lets you create whatever
insane map you want and post it to be
played by fans all over the world thank
you Oh super nice huh okay so the Far
Cry 4 map editor lets you play literally
unlimited amounts of content created by
players just like you you can design
your own Maps or you can just sit back
relax and enjoy the fruits of other
people's labour so maybe you feel like
playing a map that challenges you to
kill like 50 enemies in five minutes
with an elephant and a grenade launcher
no problem done
or okay just riffing here let's say you
want to be thrown into the middle of an
arena to face off against 50 bears and a
hundred pissed off honey badgers with
only a flamethrower and no health regen
you can totally do that or maybe you
want to challenge your friend to a
hovercraft race down a river infested
with demon fish under a hellfire of
mortars park roars map editor has that
too it's uh ow okay I'm sorry just is
everything okay
that sounds amazing go on please oh okay
um now imagine maybe I don't know maybe
you've got three minutes to reach an
extraction point leaping 100 feet in the
air
we're like what about floating islands
surrounded by demons and the demons
could have dogs sure yeah the demons
could have dogs I guess that's something
you're into explosion dogs what they're
dogs
they explode get out of here Maurice can
the dogs explode is that something that
they can explode absolutely
all right the dogs can explode again if
that's something that you're really into
it is
okay so there you have it fire cry for
map editor make your own maps play other
people's Maps anti-gravity gyrocopter
explored in books and exploding dogs
anything you could imagine
just go out there and do it find endless
adventure play top rated maps or create
your own
for our cry for map editor far cry 4 in
stores now
[Music]